The Dep Ed vision would dream of Filipinos
who passionately love their country
and whose values and competencies
enable them to realize their full potential
and contribute meaningfully to building the nation.
As a learner centered public institution,
the department of education continuously improves
itself to better serve its takeholders.
The depth admission
to protect and promote the right of average Filipino
to quality, equitable,
culture based and complete basic education
where students learn in a child friendly,
gender sensitive,
safe and motivating environment.
Teachers facilitate learning
and constantly nurture every learner.
Administrators and staff
as two words of the institution
ensure an enabling and supportive environment
for effective learning to happen.
Family, community
and other state coders erractively engage in
share responsibility in developing lifelong learners.
The depth ed core values
Makadios Makatao Makakalitasan at pakabansa.